What's up y'all? We out here at a
festival doing some dollar hunting and
so we see a booth here. God,
>> right?
>> Yes sir.
>> I'm a huge supporter of you.
>> Oh man, praise God, bro. Bill crap got
up for Congress this year, MAN. I WATCH
SWEAT DOWN OUR
>> I don't know why I can't remember your
name, but you're the one that you're
constantly chopping down the Muslims
with
David Wood. That's right. Huh?
>> What do you think we're here for? for
me.
>> Oh, well, man. Well, that's I'm actually
honored that you guys came to visit my
seat, man.
>> Yeah, man. We heard we could get some da
instruction over here.
>> All right. Just don't cause any fights,
you know, convert them. Bring them to
Christ. All right. Thank you. Nice to
meet you, man. It's a pleasure, man.
>> All right. You, too.
>> How are you?
>> How you guys doing? Avery, nice to meet
you.
>> English and Spanish.
>> Whatever information you like, I can
help you.
>> The Qurans.
>> Yeah,
>> these are free.
Okay. I got it in different languages.
That's good.
>> Yeah, we have Spanish, Chinese, Bengali.
>> Okay, nice.
>> You know what? Do you know what
translation this is?
>> Uh, I can open it, right?
>> Yeah, you can open it and and take it
take it to your home.
>> This one is the English right here.
>> This is the English.
>> This one's English. Okay. For sure.
>> All the cameras. But the one thing I
will tell you that we're not here for
debate. I know there this gentleman
tried last couple of days and I told him
very clearly that we're not here for
debate. Uh if you want to take something
go ahead. If you want to debate that's
fine but you know this is a debate cuz
we try last. He's not in
>> No, we don't have the debate.
>> Okay.
>> Could we ask questions?
>> No. Whatever you need.
>> No questions.
>> No question. We're just giving our
information.
>> We're just trying to see what
translation this is.
>> Sure.
Do you guys have a track on on Jesus?
What
>> do you guys have a track on Jesus
information on like what the Quran says
about Jesus?
>> Thank you.
>> Jesus, a prophet of God.
>> Does this teach that Jesus is like you
believe Jesus was a Muslim? A Muslim
prophet?
>> Jesus is the prophet.
>> Okay. That's why we
>> so not a Muslim particularly
>> he's a prophet all every prophet is a
Muslim that's what we do Muslim means
someone who submits themselves to God
>> okay
>> so we believe that God sent every
prophet all the prophets
>> and all the prophets taught the same
message which is to submit to God
>> so whoever submits themselves to God is
a Muslim
>> okay
>> by the definition I don't know what
Muslim is
>> would you say that uh that that's more
of a generic term or is that
specifically about like the God that's
revealed within Islam, you know, cuz cuz
like people
>> we don't think that there are different
kinds of God.
>> Okay.
>> So, like I said, that God the creator
>> Yeah.
>> He sent prophets and messengers in every
nation.
>> Yeah.
>> And all of those prophets and messengers
came with the same message
>> which is submit yourself to God. That's
>> So, so like with regards to this cuz I
understand what you're saying as far as
the language goes as a Muslim. Let's say
I I believe in one God. I believe in one
creator. Um I submit my will to him,
right? But but in this but in the same
thing, right? But in this in this
instance, I believe that like the God
that I'm referring to, the creator of
all things, I'm referring to like a
statute that I have. Would I still if I
submit to that alone and believe that's
the creator of all things, would I still
count to be a Muslim?
>> I'm very uncomfortable with with these
gentlemen here. and
and and like I understand you guys are
probably from the same, you know,
>> I don't I don't know, man. I just met
him today.
>> That's why the here's the thing. I'm
being very honest with you.
>> Last two days, we've literally been
harassed
>> by him.
>> We're being nice.
>> Yeah.
>> So So So that's why I I'm very
uncomfortable taking, you know, getting
into a debate. But like I said, we're
not here to
>> Yeah. Like
as you see, I'm not
>> if if one of us gets mean, then we'll
>> Yeah. Just we we like talking about
these type of things. It's not What was
the question again
>> about so about the you know how you
define what it means to be a Muslim
submitting to one god the one creator I
was asking if I believed in one one
creator one god I believe I submit to
that god but the god that I'm talking
about is a statute that I prostrate to
>> well the thing is if god sent a certain
guidance
>> and a individual
they
>> if they follow that guidance
>> then they are following god
>> okay
>> if they take if they do the same
not following the guidance of God.
They're not really following the
guidance.
>> Exactly. That that makes sense to me. So
I would say that being a Muslim,
>> it's it's not as simple as submit to one
God, believe in one God, and then you're
Muslim, but there's a particular
guidance you have to follow, right?
There's a like anything else, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Like anything else in life, right? Like
if you if you if you work like let's say
you you have a 9 toive job
>> and you have you have certain task that
you need to complete
>> and your boss is not breathing over your
shoulder all the time
>> but you cannot say okay you know I
finished my job on Monday morning I'm
not going to come rest of the week
>> you can't just make up your own
>> so you got to follow the certain rules
just like everything else
>> so so with that being said then in
regards to within Islam there's a
particular guidance right Allah has a
particular identity he has qualities
that are specific to him that separates
him from any of these false gods of
these false ideologies, right?
>> How would you demonstrate that Jesus
followed the guidance of Allah like the
guidance that we find in Islam that
qualifies him to be a Muslim?
>> So
the way we see things is we see things
through the lens of Islam,
>> right? Quran says that Jesus was a
prophet of God.
>> So that is that's what we believe. God
said so we believe Quran is the word of
God. Yeah.
>> And whatever Quran says he is to be to
the truth. That's what we do.
>> So the Quran says Jesus used to worship
God.
>> So he you know Jesus was a prophet of
God. So we do.
>> So like we don't kind of take a step
back look at the history of Jesus or
whatever
>> to to make sure whether he was actually
did it or not. See Quran say he's a
prophet of God. Yes. He's a prophet of
God. He's a prophet of God. Yes. He's a
prophet of God.
>> For us that's that's what suffice.
>> So I'll give you one last thing on this
topic. For example, in the Christian
Bible. M
>> right like we don't go into this whole
thing what's a Bible what's not Quran
says that there's a book that was
revealed to Jesus
>> which is sufficient for us you know what
I'm saying
>> it's sufficient for us that there was a
book delivered to Jesus
>> yeah so so this like you said a lot of
important things brother so with this
being said like obviously as Christians
we we have the gospel right and like you
said the Quran says the book was
revealed um Jesus came preaching the
gospel
Right? And the Quran confirms the
gospel. The thing is is that when we
read the gospel, we see that Jesus
followed a different guidance than what
we see in Islam. Like you know,
obviously like Allah doesn't begin nor
is he begotten, right? He has no
children. That's like blasphemous to
say, but Jesus goes around teaching that
he's the son of God in the gospel and
that he's the only way to salvation,
right? This is in the gospel. And so we
see that Jesus, the guidance that he's
coming with is completely opposite of
what we see from the Quran. So when I
hear you say that okay like Jesus was a
Muslim to me that sounds impossible just
theologically based on the type of
guidance he was following. You
understand my position?
>> I I mean I think I do.
>> Uh
>> so from the gospel that you're talking
about right
>> the way that Jesus taught it seems
different than
>> Yes.
So
>> I don't as a Muslim I don't go into
looking at what the gospel has to say
what the practice of Jesus was.
>> Okay.
>> Like it is as simple for me as does the
Quran say that Jesus was a prophet of
God.
>> Yes. He says
>> wouldn't you have to verify that though?
Like if you're
>> the Quran is what my what what I read.
You see what I'm saying? For me Quran is
a
>> I don't I don't like I said with the
historical thing I don't go back and
check.
>> That's that's important though. like you
got enough to me like because because
with the Islam literally means to submit
oneself to God.
>> Yeah.
>> So if I submitted myself to God, I don't
need to verify my I don't need to verify
what God said by looking at something
else.
>> My my thing is
>> cuz then I'm not really believing what
God is saying, right?
>> No, not necessarily. Cuz cuz I I get
what you're saying. You have full faith
in what the Quran says. I I tr I
understand your position. My thing is
that the the Quran gives verification on
what on why we should believe it. And
one of the things is to go check the
previous scriptures. We can read about
the previous prophets and we can see
that the the Quran is in line with them.
And so like B like for example, there's
one example in chapter 10:94 where Allah
says to Muhammad, if you're in doubt
about that which we have revealed to
you, then go and ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you. The
truth has come to you from your Lord. So
be not of those who doubt. So this is an
example of if not saying that Muhammad
did doubt but if he did hypothetical if
you did doubt this is what you can do go
check with the previous scriptures and
that'll clear up any doubt. So the Quran
uses the previous scriptures as a
verifier you know so like I say if
you're saying you as a Muslim you don't
need to do that at least as a Christian
who's testing this like okay I'm hearing
about it I'm reading the Quran okay it
gives me a a a way to test to see if the
Quran's valid for it.
>> Yeah. So if I if I do that and I see
that it contradicts what Jesus says, am
I fair to judge that the Quran is false?
>> You're fair. You you you are entitled to
your own opinion 100%. Right.
>> No, not not opinion but like just
>> No, no, you again you are entitled to
your own whatever you there's a verse in
religion, right? God doesn't God didn't
send me to force you into believer
whatever you don't believe, right? Yeah.
You're you're free to believe whatever
you want to. So how how do you then
reconcile this this issue in the Quran?
>> I already mentioned I already mentioned
Quran whatever Quran says is enough for
me.
>> So if it says the gospel is true is that
enough for you?
>> Quran says whatever the book was
revealed to Jesus
>> that gospel
>> it doesn't say it doesn't say gospel it
says in
>> yeah that's the gospel.
>> So what again whatever the Quran says
>> I believe if the Quran says inj is the
true
>> cuz in was revealed to Jesus was true
then I believe in it. So then you
believe that Jesus is the son of God who
came died on the cross. No
>> that's that's the dilemma. So like
>> no Quran is very explicit about saying
that this Quran is very explicit about
saying that Jesus is not the son of God.
>> I know that this is my point brother. My
point is is that look even what you're
saying. You're saying you believe what
the Quran says. Period. That's it.
That's all. Right. I'm I'm presenting
that the Quran says the gospel is true.
And then
>> you're not saying is true. Right. That's
what the gospel. the the in the gospel
that exists today there's a whole debate
about this which I'm not interested in
getting in at all is whether the gospel
today is the same as in
>> right so for me that's irrelevant
>> oh that's huge
>> that's very irrelevant
>> cuz look look brother if if it's not the
if if it's not the injil then now we
have this uh this book that the Quran is
telling Christians to use and judge by
that we don't even know if we have or
not and so but then Allah condemns the
Christians for turning away from the
gospel that they don't Yeah, that that's
that's tough for us.
>> I'm not going to make a judgment on what
God has to do with Christians or not.
>> No, he No, he already told us.
>> No. Okay, but but my point is as a
Muslim, it is sufficient for me what God
said in the Quran.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I don't have to worry about what was
sent to Jesus or what because Jesus cuz
whenever a people comes after a nation
after after a prophet, excuse me.
Whenever a people comes after a prophet
that prophet is the prophet of those
people. So whoever whoever came the
people that came between Jesus and
Muhammad they were subjected they are
prophets was Jesus. Whoever came so
whoever came after Muhammad
Union and everybody else the prophet
that God sent to us all is Muhammad.
That's what we believe. So, do you
believe that the Jews in Oh, go ahead. I
don't want to cut you off.
>> That's okay. So, so I don't need to go
back and find where the true gospel is
or true in is to verify if God is still
true or not.
>> So,
>> for me, it's sufficient that God said, I
revealed in
>> Yeah.
>> to Jesus who was a prophet of God and
that's sufficient. So the big issue here
is that if you're saying that's
sufficient for you, the Quran doesn't.
Because the Quran, for example, for the
Jews and Christians, if you go to
chapter 4:47,
it tells the Jews and the Christians,
the people of the book, it says, "Say,
oh people of the book, believe in what I
have we have sent down to you,
confirming that which is already with
you." Right? Confirming that which is
already with you.
>> Let me just read it in the Quran they're
putting out. So it says, "Oh you who
have been given the scripture, believe
in what we have revealed." It says to
Muhammad. They put in parenthesis cuz
it's not there. Revealed confirming what
is already with you. So talking about
you who've been given the scripture,
believe in what we've revealed to
Muhammad or the Quran. Why should we
believe in that? Because it's confirming
what is already with you. So it's it's
basically I think I think what God logic
is saying. know you have your reasons
for believing in the Quran and you're
saying that's efficient. But the Quran
also tells us why we should believe the
Quran. It's giving a it's giving a
message to Christians and Jews and it's
saying you Christians and Jews should
also believe in Muhammad and the Quran.
And we say why should we believe in
Muhammad and the Quran? But the reason
the reason that Jews and Christians are
supposed to believe in Muhammad and the
Quran is that it's confirming what is
already with us. And so we look at what
we have with us and God lo doesn't seem
to line up because what's with us says
that Jesus is the son of God. He died on
the cross. He rose from the dead. And
that doesn't line up with the Quran. So
that's that's basically the main
confusion we have here is this this
isn't this isn't about you. This is
about the Quran says why we're supposed
to believe in the Quran. And the reason
the main reason it gives for why we
should believe in Muhammad and the Quran
is that the Quran is affirming our
scriptures. and that our scriptures are
confirming Islam. So, we look at our
scriptures and we don't think they're
confirming Islam, which means we're
either just we're misinterpreting our
scriptures or it was a mistake to tell
us to go to our book to confirm
Muhammad.
>> All right? So,
just one thing I'll tell you is this.
Look, you as a Christian person, are you
content with what you believe?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Without a doubt.
>> Then you have no reason to look further.
>> Okay? So we shouldn't believe in Islam
if we're content.
>> If you're content, no 100%. I'm telling
you because the thing is again there's
no forcing here. There's no like there's
no intellectual gymnastics that's going
to go here. If you yourself is content
with what you believe, right? If you
yourself is content with what you
believe and you don't think there is any
like I mean you think that's the that's
the truth then you know then you what
you believe is yours what I believe is
mine.
That's where I'm going to leave it at
because you know like picking different
verses and the context you know not
knowing the context right and the
interpretation of it I don't want to get
into this conversation because I don't
know what to tell you as far as you know
how to interpret that verse you know
what I'm saying so my thing is that look
if
what I I gave you the preface of how we
believe what we believe about Jesus or
about previous scriptures for us This
Quran is the latest edition of God's
revelation and the final final final
revelation of God. What the Quran says
is what God wants the humanity to know
after prophet Muhammad. Quran says I
have sent prophets and messengers
previously and with some of them I send
scriptures with Jesus. I sent the injil
with Moses I sent the Torah for us
that's sufficient because what God wants
us to do is follow the Quran. Right? So
now if
>> wait just he wants you to follow the
Quran or everyone
>> he wants everyone who came after prophet
Muhammad cuz cuz the prophet that was
sent to these people is prophet
Muhammad.
>> So you you want us to be Muslim then?
>> Of course cuz that's what we that's what
we believe is to be the truth. Now if
you don't agree with that
>> so we judge by
>> if you don't believe in that that's
completely fine right?
>> So
>> yeah. Yeah. Go ahead. So so because you
were just saying a little bit earlier
that if we're content we should stay
Christian.
>> I'm sorry. You were just saying a little
earlier that if we're content, we should
stay Christian. But now,
>> well, I'm saying if you're content, then
there's like, you know, there there's no
like having a debate over this, right?
>> What what should we be? What what off we
to do?
>> But as I said, God would want you to
follow his last final revelation.
>> Got you.
>> And that's why we are here. We're giving
you information so for people to know
what God wanted them to follow. Now, if
you don't want to follow that because of
whatever you feel is to be the truth,
teach us to do their own, right? Okay.
>> Yeah. And I think uh I agree that what
what what you're saying about the uh
about the perspective of the Quran. To
me it seems like to me it seems like
it's saying uh Allah sent Moses and sent
revelation to Moses and there's the
revelation for Moses that was given for
the people around Moses. But Moses is
prophesying other prophets who are to
come after him. And then other prophets
come after him. And then Jesus comes and
then Jesus, he confirms Moses, but he's
also pointing to someone else who's
coming. And then Muhammad comes and he
said he's confirming Jesus and Moses.
And we're reading we're reading these
passages um like he quoted Surah 4 which
says that the reason the people of the
book shouldn't believe in Muhammad and
the Quran is because Muhammad and the
Quran are confirming the scriptures that
we have. And so it looks like our
scriptures are confirming him. he's
confirming our scriptures. And so that
seems to be the Islamic perspective that
there are all these revelations given to
Allah to different groups and they're
all confirming each other. And so as a
Muslim, you would say, okay, I believe
in I believe in uh in in these previous
revelations. And what what we're kind of
pointing out is it's not just it's not
just surah 4:47. It's it's 241, it's
289, it's 291, it's 297, it's 21101,
it's 2121. He says his the main argument
there are two main arguments that Allah
gives to Christians to say why we should
also believe because you're you're
saying you're saying that people after
Muhammad are supposed to believe in
Muhammad. I believe you're right
according to the Quran that we're all
supposed to believe in Muhammad. All
people in the book supposed to believe
in Muhammad and if we reject it then
we're kind of in trouble. But the two
reasons that the Quran gives for why we
should believe in Muhammad are one that
it's confirming our scriptures and two
that we find Muhammad mentioned in our
scriptures. So we go to our the point is
we go to our scriptures and the main
argument that Allah gives is that since
he's confirming our scriptures we should
believe in Muhammad but we go to our
scriptures and they don't line up with
Islam. So that argument seems to fail.
And then if we go to our scriptures and
we read Jesus died on the cross for
sins, he rose from the dead. He's Lord.
is the son of God. We read that. Then if
that's true and we're judging by our
scriptures, then it would seem like we
have to reject Muhammad. So the main two
arguments that Allah gives in this book
for why we should believe in Muhammad,
they don't they don't work. They don't
work. It's like it's like if I said the
main reason you should believe in me is
because if you go over there, there's
going to be a sign. It's going to say
believe in believe in David. He's a true
prophet. You go over there and it says
don't believe in David. He's he's a
liar. That that would be kind of what
the situation we're in. is saying
believe in Muhammad because of what's in
your books. We go to our books and it's
like they're saying don't believe in
Muhammad. And so that's kind of the
confusion like we we don't if that's the
main reasons then we have to reject the
main reason.
>> I don't have sufficient knowledge to you
know like to to answer you.
>> Okay.
>> Do you do you understand the the dilemma
though?
>> I think I understand the dilemma.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh like I said I don't have the
sufficient knowledge to kind of you know
>> Yeah. So, so like not notice we're not
we're not coming from a place where
we're rejecting the Quran out of our
subjective belief in like we're
Christians if you can't tell already,
but you know, we're we're Christians.
So, whatever disagrees with
Christianity, we're just going to reject
outright. No, like we we've read the the
Quran. We've seen the claims that it
made, right? And we're testing it. And
so,
>> I see you.
>> Oh, I see.
By putting
>> Ninja by putting the Quran to the test
by what it says, we're seeing that the
Quran falls short objectively, not not
based on our opinion, but just based on
what the Quran says itself and we test
out what it says that oh find Muhammad
in those scriptures. If we don't find
Muhammad in the scriptures, the Quran
made a false claim. Oh, the Quran is in
line with the previous scriptures. If
it's not in line with the previous
scriptures, the Quran's making a false
claim. So that that's the position we're
coming from. And of course if if our
scriptures have been corrupted like it
was a different jail why why doesn't
Allah say anywhere? Why does he keep
telling Christians judge by the gospel
standures
>> within the same Christian world there's
difference of opinion what what the true
Bible is right like again like it's not
something that
>> it's not a mystery or it's not like a
claim that Muslims are making right
>> within the Christian there's no
confusion there's a lot of difference
there's no gospel
>> not about the core of the gospel and
what the actual Christian scriptures are
there's difference about how to
interpret certain things but there still
is agreement on what the canon and what
the main books are of the scriptures
Anyway, so I mean like I said, I don't
have sufficient knowledge to
>> uh cater to your, you know,
>> No, that's that's why it's good because
lots of people will try to make stuff up
if they don't know. So I I respect I
haven't really studied that. That's what
I say when people are saying I look I
haven't studied that. I I don't know. So
if you want me to study it, I'll I'll
I'll look into it and get back to you.
So I respect that. Um ju just I had one
more just one more thing there. There's
as far as what we were saying about um
we're not just like dogmatic that
someone can't be um speaking the truth
or something like that because um as I'm
sure you know when Muhammad first
started receiving revelations he went to
his wife and her cousin Waka who's
supposedly Christian of some kind. We
don't we don't know a lot about him. But
Wadka heard what he was heard what the
first couple of verses that Muhammad was
receiving. And Wadka who was a Christian
of some kind said, "Hey, I believe I
believe you're getting a revelation now.
I believe you're getting a revelation."
Which I might have thought the same
thing because you're in the middle of a
bunch of polytheists and pagans. And
this guy comes out saying there's only
one God and we have to believe in Moses
and we have to believe in Jesus. And if
I were there, I'd be like, maybe this
maybe this guy is getting revelation.
Maybe this guy is getting revelation. So
I if I were in water's position, I might
have said
>> this guy might be getting true
revelations here. So we wouldn't be
opposed to somebody especially in like
some environment where they they don't
have creatures coming from other other
places enough and stuff like that. If if
God wanted to raise up a prophet to
speak to them, uh I wouldn't have a
problem with it. But Muhammad kept
receiving revelations and again he
eventually gave reasons why everyone
should believe in him. And if it were
some other reason where we looked at it
and said, "Oh wow, this is a really good
point. this lines up with what we with
what we believe. That might be
interesting. That might be making us
think maybe we should believe in him.
But when we look at his main reasons for
believing and they just they don't line
up when we go and investigate him, uh
it's kind of an issue. But um so yeah,
we think that's a serious issue. But
yeah, we we'll uh we we we respect you
haven't looked into it. That's very
respectful.
>> Yeah, we appreciate. Can we shake your
hand?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It was very nice to meet you
guys.
>> For sure.
>> I said I could take a couple of these,
right?
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. Take care, guys. Thanks for this.
>> Friendly like you, that would be nice.
>> Be be nicer, Stanley.
>> To be fair, we're not all we're not
always nice. If someone else is mean,
then we get we we
guys are nice, so we're respectful.
Yeah.
>> Can I Can I take one of these?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Sure.
>> Thanks, guys.
>> Keep that. Keep that. Speak. You want to
give this to a day with a quality
speaker?
>> Yeah, we'll do a wrap up. Okay.
>> We're going to do a wrap up right here.
>> Take one of each.
>> No. No. Just right here.
>> Right here. We do the background.
>> Okay. Yeah. How's the How's the light?
We good? We're going to do a wrap up
real quick.
>> A rapid
>> wrap up. Yeah. Like a little conclusion.
I I want you to do
a rap wrap around. How you going to get
around that?
>> What is David doing? Well, okay. He's
over there talking. So in conclusion,
IP, I want to know what you sum sum
summised from the discussion there.
>> Yeah, I observed most I enjoy observing
it. It was interesting cuz you know they
were uh they were really kind of
concerned at first and then we you did a
good job calming them down questions.
>> Then we start going through the Islamic
dilemma. Point out that hey there's
there's some real issues here. We're not
rejecting Islam because of just
animosity or Christian bias. We're doing
it because of what Quran tells us. We
are following what Allah told us to do
at the end of the day. Yeah. Exactly. So
with that being said, guys, we see that
the Islamic dilemma has no answers. Um
and it doesn't matter what dawa table
you go to. No shake, no imam, no da guy
is going to be able to answer that.
They're all going to be stumped on that.
It's going to be it's over. Every
Christian when you watch this, pick up
the verses that we mentioned. We only
mentioned a couple. You you learn a
couple of those verses. It's over. I'm
telling you, it's over. All right. God
bless you guys, man. Make sure you guys
hit the like button. Tell us who your
favorite was in the comment section. And
uh we'll see youall in the next one.